[Music]
give me your money let's go hurry up
maybe quick right
[Music]
good afternoon ma'am could have a pack
of condoms please 20 minutes ago
the quest was late what superhero takes
the bus Mikado's wings don't work if
your wings don't work then why you put
the mother dog branding the same reason
you wear that raggedy-ass hoodie if you
can't show up on time these people never
trust you to be a superhero
I'm trying oh we don't know that you
wouldn't in here your finger press it on
that man I'm so sorry
that's my brother can you delete
definitely surveillance thing I said
there one is way too strong hey check it
out we at the spa we live as hell man
and who do we run into but hey so Luke
tell us how it all went down
I believe it or not I didn't have
anything to do with this one the night
pigeon heroically defended this woman's
store he's a hero
yo he was like a rad duel wings actually
the pigeon is a highly intelligent hey
whatever it meant get a picture with me
and look he's a hero
hmm we should get the buddy little space
good man I just wish you could do the
same - that dudes been stealing packages
off my stoop people have been stealing
some packages not some man all if you
order from that website package pros is
as good as gone my day job was over a
package
Oh Street you live on that Dexter Avenue
look to me like Dexter I've need a hero
look kid I'm a chicken that is that's
what's up man hey what's your name again
they call me the night oh it's the
farm Ratburn worry about them you win
the people over it just takes time put a
silent alarm bar robbery I got it under
control chief he's sleep sleep yep huh
right
third time this week ya know is that the
type of hero you want to be no then get
out there and catch that package thief
the city needs a night pitcher you're
right
hey Reggie 1 come help me mood his dead
body alright
you